you're grouping every okay yes every
Islamic country I'm grouping every
single one I'm grouping well Muslims
together every single imma country I'm
grouping that's just I can't just can't
you're feeling every single AMA country
yes your floor every single one I'll
give you that what floor your floor yes
you're saying it as though it's a bad
thing every single Islamic country yes
I'm grouping them together your floor um
you got invite yourself some Muslims on
the show like we've had many Muslims
okay so let me many many Muslims we have
we've had Imam Chaudhary on the show
we've had we've invited talked Islam on
the show who personally issued critiques
in me with millions of plays the biggest
Islamic nonprofit on YouTube they
refused to come up they refused to come
on the show we had what was your name
any Cyrus in the show who's a former
Islamic child bride we had a woman named
cute we have to call her Q on the show
who left her husband again a Sharia
court here in the United States it was
not recognized by the state abuser tried
to take the children and she is in
hiding right now because he just needs
to say divorce divorce divorce and she
has no recourse to get her kids back
this is very common in Dearborn and in
the United States it's not an outlier
we've had a lot of Muslims on the show
will comment if it's so common then how
is it I know so many progressive Muslims
in the United States how is that was it
by like possibly because you're hanging
out with secular lesbian Muslims at
nightclubs no but like I mean seriously
litter come on you have to acknowledge a
lesbian blogger who wears a hijab is not
representative of Islam and when I say
hundreds of million and you say but
there are some who don't it's not a
valid counter-argument that you have a
lesbian Muslim friend it's like saying I
have a black friend uh Mona Eltahawy in
Egypt like go look out there there are
these people or not and oh I'm in
samples who wanna oh your phone is you
just thinking on the thing is the feed
has given us a crappy round trip can we
can we bring her back a new battle
doesn't need to be more progressive yes
it does they oh great
[ __ ] okay sorry hold on a second I
didn't I didn't hear I didn't hear that
last part because you're your thing when
my partner is the radio on us it's her
fault blaming
her dad well just convert to Islam and
beat the hell out of her
oh oh come on now and other faiths man I
just know here's the deal you talk about
Egypt how are gays how are apostates
treated in Egypt so you can point to one
person but what's the law in Egypt I'm
not defending Egypt I'm also by the way
you wanna do it as a man of progressive
Muslims one person but what's the law in
Egypt Egypt neck okay once upon a time
in this country you can be criminalized
for having anal sex 26 - no I see that
as a I didn't see that as right but the
point is we progressed right we
progressed in our religions we progress
in our laws we progress in our norms you
wouldn't have taken a snapshot of
Christianity Judaism and the American
value system at that moment in time and
said oh you know what that's inherently
what's okay so what snapshot should we
take then to be fair to Islam
what snapshot in history I do not want
to give it a chance to progress and by
the way Egypt before you know the before
the Muslim Brotherhood was a more
progressive place just like Iran in 1969
was more progressive there was now so
allow for some Mohandas you're right I
agree I guess I just don't understand
you I agree with you Oh religion I agree
with you even it even if it's what 50
percent 40 percent 30 percent 60 percent
whatever percent it is far more who but
my point is let's not argue the percents
for just a second well it matters if you
bring up one lesbian a job wearing
friend and hundreds of millions of
Muslims and iris know out of 1.6 billion
Stephen and I promise you if 1.6 billion
we're like you're describing knew you'd
notice it would almost look like the
Islamic world uh it would almost look
like Egypt you're analogizing or UAE
Isis no I'm not UAE is bad enough Qatar
is bad enough
have you been to Indonesia Indonesia
isn't you right there they are burning
churches and record numbers in Indonesia
right now this year I'm not I'm not
defending them what you just said
Indonesia is different there's it's
indefensible it's indefensible at the
point there's no Islamic country in the
history of the world that has a
defensible a defensible track record not
what
my point here is I'm not gonna my point
here is huh why do you want to paint
everyone else no let me answer a
question I can't go to Indonesia because
of a fatwa on my head for drawing a
profit let me go so I that know that
that matters and that's that's wrong and
I disagree with that now
and that's mainstream why wouldn't you
want to support support the progressive
forward-thinking Muslim Muslims in their
efforts to reform and lead therefore I
do better no you want a lien I've
written a column right here no go I'll
send it to you I have it up right here
louder with credit calm we need you in
the civil war against Islam Islam needs
a civil war just as bloody as the United
States Civil War fought to free the
slaves right they need a civil war and
the minority will have to fight off the
majority they'll have to fight to
abolish apostasy laws they'll have to
fight to create equal rights for women
they'll have to fight to create equal
rights for gay well just pick gay people
not being killed they need a civil war
and I wrote a column support we need you
to do it because we can't do it on our
own
yes and they're sure listening to you
the way that your alienating them and
making them all feel I'm not listening
to you because you're lesbian and they
hate you
that and the moderate Muslims do not
hate me again what do we do listening to
yourself yes they do
well then I'm so confused I've been to
Dearborn and I didn't get like stabbed
as a tear born is a crapple to the board
okay here's the one thing this is this
is like when liberals say with climate
deniers right when little say when when
you have climate on this is like when
conservatives the dumb arguments where
they go like well my neighbor who
doesn't be an otter so there's no global
warming it's silly it's also silly for
you say I went to Dearborn and I didn't
get beheaded so dear what Dearborn is a
hotbed for terrorism not gay Jared knows
I won't bring him in because it's not
fair the restaurant that I went to was
caught funneling money to Hezbollah
called Lachish and now they just changed
it to another place it is so common in
Dearborn everybody knows it so that's a
great example for you to use I
understand we don't apply the same
standard to Islam as you do to
Christians I mean you blame the Orlando
shooting on Christians the Colorado
shooting on Christians
mass shootings on Christians I have it
right here oh whoa
I blame fundamentalism on the ills and
harms of fundamentalism that's it and I
mean and and if you read the nuance
right fine you know I mean this is
pretty simple right come on you know
that little cute boys fundamentalist
Islam that fundamentalist Christianity
that okay okay let me take that point I
agree oh I agree I agree I agree I agree
okay so let's take that that's really
important right
no let me ask you let me answer that
because that's important I agree so
fundamentalist Christian let's say the
most fundamentalist Christian right
Jesus
okay are you not I wouldn't argue that
now okay
so G let's say I would argue I would
argue for instance that you know fred
phelps very severely with 12 members of
the Westboro Baptist Church and what
they say is [ __ ] in Iran you get
thrown off a rooftop I do not think
Jerry Falwell and I think a lot of
Christians would take oh okay so let me
make my point that I was making pray to
this okay the baseline the jumping off
point Jesus right okay Jesus okay Jesus
never killed somebody
Jesus never beat his wife she does never
advocate to beat your wife Jesus never
caused award Jesus never be had anyone
Jesus never called for the killings of
Christians and Jews Jesus never
established even a form of law Mohammed
did all of those things so could we
agree that Muhammad himself would be a
radical fundamentalist that we would
both have a problem with I'm good I I
don't even I listen you know I'm an Old
Testament girl as a Jew and uh the god I
read about in the Old Testament was a
pretty scary dude did some pretty awful
things so you know drowned all humanity
at one point fire bombed all of Sodom
right like did some call for people to
be murdered for this and that like
impose some pretty harsh you know the
penalty for is the penalty for like uh
jealousy and I mean like really ugly
harsh penalties I'm gonna hold you the
question but yes I mean I don't I don't
that to me right is I don't therefore
say Oh God is a right-wing force right I
know but cessful you didn't answer the
question
at all
well second while I'm in a you're right
I'm totally pumped in your question get
somebody who's a scholar of the club but
why is why wouldn't it be
you're just saying you talk up no no
this is important this is important this
is important Sally because you talk
about some guy who has an inbred
congregation of 12 people as though it's
this grave concern meanwhile you have
the founder of the feast Mohammed who
beat his wife who advocated for the
deaths of Christians and Jews who
beheaded people who committed mass
terrorism you're writing about a guy
with 12 people most of whom are inbred
kids with flippers and you're not
worried about the guy who 1.6 billion
Muslims follow that should concern you
what I'm trying to say Stephen is first
of all you know please bring on someone
who actually is a believer not we have
Vic not a critic but who is I mean I'm
happy to suggest you a long list of
people who are angel scholars and can
and on the different interpretations as
well that's knowing but Sally it's it's
not a it's not a rebuttal to my question
even and I'm also by the way not an
expert on Jesus so don't be true it's
not I'm not trying to get that's not a
gotcha that's well-known stuff answering
your question which is to say first of
all um this isn't just about Westboro
Baptist Church you know as well as I do
that extreme homophobia misogyny all of
these things have unfortunately been
part of mainstream mainstream
Christianity and Judaism in their
history they were there's no arguing
that so you can say it came from Jesus
or not or worse they came from human yet
it doesn't come from Jesus doesn't
matter my plan it comes directly from
Mohammed so it existed and now it
doesn't because those faith traditions
progressed and so yes it's not true
though it's not true the gross no it's
not true it's not true in Christendom it
was never okay to beat your wife it was
never considered okay
it's unilaterally agreed-upon in Islam
no it wasn't you've always been
you've always been made him to be a
pariah you've always been excommunicated
from society it's never been okay to
beat your wife in the United States ever
misogyny has never been something that's
been lauded or approved in the United
States
slavery was endorsed in the Bible and
when our country was trying to believer
is not endorsed in the Bible mainstream
Christian faiths were citing the Bible
and saying no no no we shouldn't we
Lavery was not endorsed in the Bible and
there's still
slavery in the Islamic world why don't
we talk about that in 2016 because the
point is hey isn't it great that
Christianity and Judaism by and large
although not entirely have progressed
further have moved forward I by the way
love this conversation because we're
arguing in favor of progressivism and
against these regressive and and
oppressive norms so great let's
encourage Islam to get there too but
we're not going to do it if we insist
wrongly that the majority of Muslims do
not want that - you're incorrect but I
will say this we are arguing I will
agree with you on this we are arguing
for progressive rights we are arguing
for I wouldn't say progressive rights we
are arguing for equal rights we're
arguing for freedom right and there is
nothing that's a better failsafe for
that than the Constitution and to see
that usurped by people in Sharia Courts
as we've seen in Europe as we've seen in
the Islamic world I think would be a
catastrophe for both you and myself I
agree it would be a catastrophe it's a
good thing it's not happy it is
happening governments keep it is
happening
keeping institutions in check and look
seventy five percent of marriages in the
UK aren't even recognized twenty percent
of women who reported are abuse and
Islamic marriages here in the United
States
half of these spousal abuse situations
are settled in some form of a Moscow
Sharia Court because they're not allowed
to go to the law this is a problem right
now against it well why aren't you out
there fighting for these women not
Steven I am I don't buy all these dating
and saying that Sharia law can be
progressive it's not God I didn't say
that I said Sharia the concepts of
Sharia so when we ask in polls or as
Newt Gingrich said we should ask people
when they come to the border
do you believe in Sharia and if they say
yes we don't let them in our country
well that reflects a fundamentalist
misunderstanding of what should you so
much Sharia law expert charity Muslims
it's not what he said
talking about Sharia and Americans use
it now they just say Sharia and even if
you don't like it Sharia law looks
different in many different countries
but look I am fighting it is not one of
my branch of Sweden I'm fighting it by
supporting I'm fighting it by supporting
the majority of peaceful freedom Lebanon
majority it's not a majority just look I
don't know what to tell you man yeah
your friends aren't the same as
statistic that's the process oh you're
right ben shapiro we're all these
purrs come from who looked at the Pew
data and said oh my gosh the majority
video long before Ben Shapiro on modern
Islam you know what and it got
fact-checked and it's wrong it is based
on a fallacious my video got fat checked
and it's wrong no but Ben's did is
overly broad with the assumption that
when people answer a question and say oh
this that that Sharia it means their
right-wing Muslims you've got just it's
wrong and I'm surprised you don't care
about you're wrong I'm surprised that
you don't care about everything that
you've been wrong regarding statistics
give an example polls a majority of
Muslims do support some form of Sharia
apostasy laws or spousal abuse laws in
some case where there should be recourse
in a Sharia Court not in a secular court
right a good point is let's say the UAE
right now conversion is death right in
progressive countries Qatar you can't
leave the faith and women are treated as
second-class citizens in marriage right
any kind of extramarital sex is
punishable by death
that would mean homosexuality that would
mean adultery well guess what if you're
Muslim
you can't leave so if you're gay you
can't be a Muslim and you can't leave
either way you're die either way you die
I'm not I'm not just the thing is I'm
not supporting that I'm against all that
well this is every Islamic country and
these people are coming in record
numbers and bringing their laws here and
their beliefs here you're grouping every
okay yes every Islamic country I'm
grouping every single one I'm grouping
well Muslims together every single i'ma
country I'm grouping that's just I can't
just can't you're feeling every single
AMA country yes your floor every single
one I'll give you that
what floor your floor yes you're saying
it as though it's a bad thing every
single Islamic country yes I'm grouping
them together your floor and yet you
want to write off places like Uganda
which have implemented equally egregious
and offensive and backwards laws under
the explicit citation
of Christianity with the encouragement
of churches in the United States you say
no no not gonna blame Christianity there
no I'm not
here's the thing you don't know look you
don't want to look at political context
and I mean this is really what this
comes down to Stephen we don't say oh no
look they're full issues in the ridge of
it's their political context you look at
any of that you say no it's Islam and by
the way it's not just even Islam is
implemented in those places are
implemented by those right-wing
demagogues you know no it's just all of
Islam and in fact anyone who doesn't
believe that not only are they a
minority but I'm gonna like I'm gonna
diss you know discourage them or
disempower them or whatever by being
like oh no you're just a fringe in Islam
you're not even legitimate Islam because
legitimate Islam is there's only this
thing and by the way you want to know
the only other group that agrees with
you that would be friggin Isis that's
their message their messages you want to
be a Muslim this is the only way to be a
Muslims to believe these things I didn't
say that so it's this again with the
rewind button you're putting words in my
mouth that I didn't say let me so can i
I gave you the floor and I said no can I
say can i clarify my position because I
feel that's an inaccurate representation
I would like and I think that in these
conversations as Dinesh D'Souza says
it's only it's only productive if you if
you address your opposition fairly I
said every single Islamic country now
again the context we want talk the
context and we're talking about leaders
here in the United States saying we
can't allow the kind of laws the mindset
the cultural issues that plague every
Islamic country to permeate the United
States that they have Europe you've said
well there are some progressive examples
there's not one in the Islamic world so
I want to be clear I have said every
single Islamic country their system of
laws are ones that I would find AB or
n't to have in the United States and in
comparison to every Islamic country that
we both agree on you point to Uganda um
for the record I would find it important
to have India's laws right that words
progressive you know right-wing nation
love who's not Muslims can't blame Islam
but every single Islamic country at what
point do we see that statistically
significantly well by the way I wouldn't
like Cuba's laws but I'm not blaming
Christians for Cuba I'm because it has
nothing it well here's why here's why
you're like cuz we're talking about
Sharia law Christians if you talk if you
talk about Jesus this is the big
difference being Jesus in Mohammed right
we both know that you know there's
political context Mohammed was a
political figure Jesus wasn't Jesus said
given a Caesar what Caesar's
Wow he stepped out of it entirely
Muhammad didn't he got into politics so
Cuba can have people who are Christians
and that has nothing to do with
communism has nothing to do with a
distinctly Atheist worldview the
Communist Manifesto
it's a Sharia law here's the difference
Islam is inherently a political and
legal system that's the difference it
again
I really please reach out to someone
like Abdul Halim who would argue
vociferously and in fact many Islam's
scholars of Islam would say that no in
fact that that's the politicization of
Islam is in fact there's note that it's
impossible that in the Quran you can't
actually take the faith and implement
politically that it's that it's a that
those two things it's an impossibility
under the writings of the crime ask me
more than that and I'm gonna send you to
someone else but right let me go back
you know we in this country proudly say
okay our laws our judeo-christian laws
right there influenced by
judeo-christian morality we didn't
actually take the Bible thank God and
literally make it our law because you
know there's stonings in that too right
so we didn't do that but they're
influenced contextually not familiar and
for worse okay go for better and worse
and and again to say that well in the
United States because we like our laws
therefore that's judeo-christian we're
so happy to proclaim that but in a Cuba
or Venezuela we're not gonna say it's
judeo-christian because we don't I mean
those are also judeo-christian states or
in fact Christian states right there and
they're influenced by Christian laws and
Christian lawmakers who then adopted
their beliefs into those going to all of
Latin America right no no oh no because
no has why house huh okay what the name
of the gentleman Houston state can we
just ask me why I said no okay can I say
no I don't think that communism in Cuba
certainly that comes that stems we both
know from a distinctly atheist ideology
communism ah distinctly nihilistic
anti-god theology sorry philosophy I
don't think comparing Cuba the United
States for people who were deeply
personally deistic Christians whatever
you wanted to call them
is the same as a system of law based
expressly on the Quran and hadith and
Muhammad's word but and you cannot find
Jesus quotes for the laws of our country
in Latin America where you know they
follow a different right the prosperity
gospel and it's very much
right their laws actually and and there
are right strains of Christianity and
the prosperity gospel and Latin there
sir okay let me also make a point
no no I'm genuinely I'm surprised by
that Stephen um I thought there was a
Joel Osteen thing percentage of
Protestants Christians in the United
States in 2000 2016 this year 2016 who
favor same-sex marriage Sally
any guess you've got so far wasn't it is
that this is that the same as beating
your wife and throwing a gay off a
rooftop burning gaze alive I don't
believe marriage is a fundamental human
right am i am I like you Jer a second
here even that's not my point I'm just
comparing apples and apples 99 you
hearing us you comparing apples and
suicide bombers I'm not listen to my
point 37 percent 39 percent of
Protestants in this country in the
United States and 2016 support same-sex
marriage 42 percent of Muslims did 39
percent of Protestants 42 percent of
Muslims Muslims in this country and the
United States are a pro gay marriage and
you just said you said you said they're
all those are aberrations yes as it
relates to the Islamic world Stephen why
it's you can't judge no you can't judge
yours you need to take your no to take
your exactly and I really have to go
here so to take your exact point right
to take your exact point talking about
the United States judeo-christian rules
now you're having it on both sides of
the coin you cannot compare when
Islamists have power when Muslims have
power and are able to create and
maintain their own systems and
governments for centuries you can't
compare that with people who have no
political power or legislative ability
in the United States where a vast
portion of them are secularized Muslim
like your lesbian Muslim friend who
wears a hijab who will get stoned in any
Muslim country
calling them secularized is insulting
and it's reinforcing as I said the ISIS
notion of Islam that the only true Islam
is right-wing fundamentalist Islam
number one and number two stop doing the
right-wing yeah yes you know it's BS and
I know it is there's no reason we're
friends here my my point is stop making
it about the religion it's about the
political context there are progressive
and evolved notions I mean it's about
the right left I mean in their MOOC no
but then how do you end up with Muslims
in this country more tolerant on issues
of gay rights than groups of mainstream
Christians how do you how do you and I
can say it's about the religion yeah
yeah well anywhere the religion has been
the basis for a system of laws for
centuries throughout history you can't
point me to any example you can't point
me to any example you can't wait any
example of an Islamic majority country
where there's basic human rights ever in
the history of the world you can that's
not that that's my point and so my point
is these people would be better served
to acknowledge the problem to to reject
the teachings of someone like Muhammad
Muhammad himself and and move into the
new world
they're rejecting the the fundamentalist
backwards interpretations of their faith
that's every Muslim country now you're
being insulting right but it's not
inherent to the faith yes it is
this isn't Muhammad did those things you
and I had this conversation if you look
look Muhammad's dead dude as by the way
is there all these people rebate these
are based on human beings right we're
talking about Imams we're talking about
political you know totalitarian leaders
and their human interpretations of these
faiths and I agree with you there
they're some really can I say stop how
dare you what can I say got some nerve
on you miss cone there's some step
interpretations thereof right and there
have been but it's certain
interpretations as simple if you take
here's some here's my point if we had
this conversation 100 years ago I would
hope you would also be saying these
things about other tree why I would I
would and here's the deal here's a deal
you interpret Jesus's teachings and his
life literally it's a very different
outlook than Mohammed one is terrorism
one is a guy who might be too nice of a
neighbor you might have a net Flanders
okay before you leave I'm Ricky leave we
were talking with many had
I know you oh it's no secret your
lesbian by the way it was a like 75
years ago that Jordan decriminalized
homosexuality first country in the world
to decriminalize homosexuality and it
doesn't matter doesn't matter because
right now right now there are gross
violations of human rights in Jordan
there are but you're saying it's
inherent in them being it is it's not
you have to take the whole you have to
take the context of the whole sali
oh you absolutely have to just like
Westboro Baptists are an outlier then
you would take the whole of the United
States and say for the vast majority of
our history we believe in the
subjugation of people based on race no I
wouldn't you're gonna take the whole I
wouldn't as a matter of fact we were not
singularly unique and creating slavery
as it still exists in the Islamic world
but we were singularly unique in our
bloodiest war in history - stop it dude
yeah we're half the country fought to
keep it again if you're gonna look at
the totally lost where they are now I'm
just sayin
they lost I'm saying Steven under your
standards right if you're gonna say oh
we can't oh forget that Jordan once was
more Pro gay than it is now yeah we're
looking at the totality because it's an
Islamic nation during that same period
women didn't have equal rights well so
during that same period non-muslims
didn't have equal rights because gay
people were allowed to smooch on the
sidewalk doesn't make me think Jordan
was a bastion of equality forgive me for
not being convinced for most of our
history neither were we thank God we did
better and we move forward and we
progressed and and others can too that's
I know maybe they can but it's a great
threat to - right now Islam as it is
there's a great threat to Western
civilization Western values that you
enjoy and I enjoy and I think that that
is something it is not inherently a
threat fundamentalist Islam yes is a
threat just as is fundamentalist
Christian and analyst Judaism
fundamentals Buddhism not you know
before we go I want to I want to give
this your your I don't think I'm
bringing out of closet as far as we had
fun yeah yeah your I don't think I'm
opening the closet door and saying
you're a lesbian oh I'm like very gay
yes okay but and I will says about
FoxNews it's different on Twitter you
never struck me as a social justice
constantly offended type oh my god I'm
so offended
well exactly but like did you see this
week I just got to be funny have you
talked about this that people got
furious we were get into talking about
other things that men can have periods -
you must did you see that oh so it was
if men had periods I'm less of an expert
on men then I am on being a Muslim so no
this is this is true no was I was when I
was wondering your thought on this
because we've talked about some issues
we were on the Alan calm show on the
free-for-all and even I would say
someone like you even though I think
you're grossly wrong on Islam um there's
a new breed of leftist LGBTQA AIP who
are unbelievably offended at everything
and it seems like there's been even more
backlash against the gay community
because of it how have you been dealing
with that lady cuz you don't strike me
as that well you bet you're like okay
this guy's an ass and you can ignore it
and you don't need to start a March uh
yeah well you know I have been around
the block a little bit right so from CNN
and before that being the openly gay
lefty on Fox News so I had the develop
sort of a thick skin but you know the
truth is listen I am also a very big
proponent of treating people decently
and you know I do think yes we can
always be sometimes we go too far
outraged culture whatever but at the
same time it also seems like some people
are trying to go out of their way to
offend people and and to do so to make
political points and I just that's never
been my style I don't want to offend you
I don't want to offend anyone and if
someone come up to me and says you know
what that's offensive I'm gonna try to
do my best to listen with an open mind
and learn which is by the way how I came
to learn more about Islam I you know I
just think at FoxNews oh I've use a MOOC
speaking of FoxNews oh I always want it
because you were you were you're gay you
were gay at Fox News I assume that
didn't change yes yeah the interns
you know the hiring practices don't act
like you don't know don't act like you
don't know you would walk in and you'd
be like this is is this Abercrombie I I
remember I remember wondering because
the only lesbian I knew it function like
I wonder what Sally thinks of this cuz
you gotta be she's got to be conflicted
because she's a lesbian
but she also doesn't want to see people
hired for their looks
uh I mean listen though I'm I don't know
where to go with this okay all right out
it but you know it come on you but
you're foxy and you know I was mad that
you were a good looking dude well they
always ask me to put on a sports jacket
there's nothing my lesbianism to say
that well thank you very much I
appreciate it they they always ask me to
put on a sports jacket I got a call
you know the second floor the old second
floor and hey listen can you wear
something more than a button-down or a
polo I was like um I can and uh an actor
eight act your age okay Sally Kohn
where's the best place for people to
find you the Twitter is Sally Kohn Koh n
this has been you know delightful well
I'm on I think it's been friendly I hope
you made a few more Muslim friends out
of it well you know it's funny I was
raised and I'll let you go this I was
raised in a Montreal so I had a school
that was um significant portion Muslim
and I've written about this I watched
them cheer when 9/11 happened I watch
them make jokes so when you're outside
of the United States and get into
multicultural enclaves um this was very
common what huh all of them uh a
majority of them the fact that anyone
did and felt comfortable is appalling my
point is when they were outside of the
United States this happened all the time
every single day my Muslim friends every
single one sali every single one hated
Jews
this is Anika every every single wall
Wow every single Muslim friend I had at
Centennial Regional High hated Jews and
mine don't and by the way a lot of
Christian friends growing up who hated
Jews I didn't describe it to
Christianity I scribed it to them being
backwards [ __ ] yeah the difference
we had wrecked we had all kinds of honor
killings and stuff and we have all kinds
of wife's beatings and kidnappings
because of Islam in Quebec they have
more political power there my point is I
would have defended you I would have
defended you to my anti-semitic Muslim
friends thanks like all right Sally
thanks we'll have to have you back this
was fun super real all right take care
hey
like this video or you're still here
subscribe uh I don't know why you're
still here this is the Internet and this
is probably going on for like 35 minutes
don't you have somewhere to be
well I 1331 Mints 31 31 minutes that's
far too long